[Applaus]
in der ersten hälfte 2018 haben
us-truppen und verbündete den großteil
west türe ins zurückerobert die provinz
idlib im nordwesten wurde dabei zum
auffanglager und zur letzten hochburg
der rebellen
eine offensive des regimes wir seit
monaten erwartet heute in feuchtinger
kompakt der kampf um mitglied
[Musik]
für syriens präsidenten assad hat die
oberen von niegripp absolute
militärische priorität
er könnte sich damit nach sieben jahren
bürgerkrieg endgültig als sieger
präsentieren
für die rebellen geht es darum diese
niederlage zu vermeiden und doch noch
als politischer vertreter der opposition
wahrgenommen zu werden und einen sitz am
verhandlungstisch zu ergattern blieb
ungefähr so groß wie das bundesland
salzburg ist außerdem von großer
wirtschaftlicher bedeutung
die region gilt als tor zur türkei die
autobahnen von aleppo nach damaskus und
nach latakia an der küste führen durch
dieses gebiet beherbergt aber auch knapp
drei millionen syrer eine militärische
offensive könnte noch einmal
hunderttausende in die flucht treiben
und in eine humanitäre katastrophe
münden
wer kontrolliert idlib derzeit etwa
70.000 großteils dschihadistische kriegs
erfahrene und hoch motivierte kämpfer
befinden sich in idlib
sie können ein grob in zwei etwa gleich
große aber stark fragmentierte
gruppierungen unterteilt werden dass al
qaida komitee zur befreiung der levante
und die von der türkei gegründete lokale
nationale befreiungsfront ersatzkräfte
bereiten schon seit monaten einen
angriff vor
durch bislang konnten sie durch die
türkei den iran und russland davon
abgehalten werden
diese staaten haben seit oktober 2017
einen ring von beobachtungsposten um die
schutzzone ii blieb gezogen damit war es
möglich kampfhandlungen einzudämmen und
größere gefechte zu vermeiden
russland und die türkei hatten sich
weiters im september 2018 im russischen
sotschi auf eine pufferzone geeinigt das
ist ein 15 bis 25 kilometer breites
gebiet streifen entlang der iller
syrischen frontlinie in dem waffen und
kämpfer verboten sind
zur situation ende 2018 die
kampfhandlungen sind zwar stark
zurückgegangen doch finden weiterhin
artillerie gefechte zwischen den
rebellen und dem syrischen
team statt es gibt auch ständig
gewaltsame auseinandersetzungen zwischen
den beiden rebellen gruppieren
die al-kaida-kämpfer und andere
hardliner weigern sich die waffen
niederzulegen und die demilitarisierte
zone zu verlassen
russland untersatz bezichtigen außerdem
die rebellen in aleppo chlorgas
eingesetzt zu haben
wie kann es nun weitergehen während das
syrische regime auf eine militärische
lösung drängt setzen russland und die
türkei auf verhandlungen
der iran als vierter im bunde bevorzugt
eine rückeroberung des gesamten
territoriums durch hat teheran erwartet
sich dadurch eine stabilisierung syriens
und wirtschaftlichen nutzen
drei szenarien sind daher denkbar
erstens eine eroberung eclipse das wird
eine umfassende offensive des regimes
betreten und die massive
luftunterstützung durch russland
erfordern die rebellen könnten sich in
diesem fall wieder auf den gemeinsamen
feind konzentrieren und die
gegenseitigen kempfeld hintanstellen
der krieg würde wieder angeheizt und
hunderttausende vertriebene wären
gezwungen abermals zu fliehen
zweitens das einfrieren des konfliktes
ein nationaler dialog prozess die
ausarbeitung einer neuen verfassung und
eine pragmatische annäherung zwischen
azad und im westen sollen zu einer
politischen lösung des konfliktes führen
das würde allerdings das problem der
existenz von zigtausend dschihadisten
die weiterkämpfen wollen nicht lösen
außerdem hätte er sein ziel einer
rückeroberung des gesamten landes nicht
erreicht drittens eine offensive leid
dieses szenario beruht auf räumlich
begrenzten angriffen der regime kräfte
dabei werden die jeweiligen rebellen vor
die wahl gestellt zu kapitulieren oder
im kampf zu unterliegen
zunächst würde die schwächste fraktion
angegriffen um die anderen zu bewegen
die waffen niederzulegen
die zivilbevölkerung könnten über
korridore fliegen
diese taktik uhr die im letzten jahr
bereits mehrfach angewendet
das regime und seine unterstützer
könnten damit die opposition endgültig
zerschlagen und gleichzeitig
terroristische gruppierungen
was ist somit erwartbar aufgrund der
bisherigen entwicklungen deutet vieles
auf eine offensive leid hin
damit könnten wohl assad und seine
verbündeten am ehesten ihre ziele
erreichen türkei loyale kräfte hätten
die möglichkeit noch rechtzeitig aus
nach norden abzuziehen
ankara bliebe dabei von einem
gesichtsverlust bei seinen verbündeten
verschont auch der internationale
aufschrei wäre vermutlich deutlich
leiser als im falle einer großoffensive
allerdings dieser krieg hat bisher immer
wieder gezeigt dass sie mit üblichen
maßstäben nicht zu messen ist und alles
ganz anders kommen kann